es wurden hinweise für leben auf dem
mars gefunden
rauchen zerstört das y-chromosom und der
hi virus also aids wird schwächer das
sind drei der themen jetzt in den krieg
zum top five -
rauchen kann das y-chromosom zerstören
wissenschaftler haben herausgefunden
dass männliche raucher bis zu vier mal
wahrscheinlicher blutzellen ohne y
chromosomen besitzen als nichtraucher
das ist besonders besorgniserregend da
vor kurzem eine studie einen
zusammenhang zwischen dem verlorenen
y-chromosom und einer kürzeren
lebensspanne feststellen konnte zudem
soll das krebsrisiko höher sein
allerdings gibt es keinen direkten
beweis dafür dass der verlust des y
chromosoms krankheiten hervorruft die
einzigen faktoren die der studie zufolge
mit dem verlust des chromosoms
zusammenhängen waren alter und rauchen
die beiden wissenschaftler vermuten dass
bestimmte zellen des immunsystems durch
die fehlenden y chromosomen außer
gefecht gesetzt werden und der körper
deshalb wahrscheinlicher von krebs
befallen wird die gute nachricht für
alle raucher die schäden die durch das
rauchen verursacht werden sind umkehrbar
und abhängig von der menge an
konsumierten zigaretten
aliens werden vermutlich tausende
lichtjahre von uns entfernt leben das
errechnete ein astrobiologe mit einer
abänderung der drake gleichung mit neuen
daten aus der kepler mission seine
ergebnisse schränkte er auf planeten in
ähnlicher größe und in der bewohnbaren
zone 1 demzufolge könnte es einfaches
leben in zehn bis hundert lichtjahren
entfernung zu uns geben dass werden
allerdings ein zähler oder andere
bakterien intelligente aliens sofern sie
tatsächlich gibt wären allerdings erst
in tausenden lichtjahren entfernung also
einer richtig großen distanz zu uns
möglich
und nochmal aliens hinweise für leben
auf dem mars gefunden forschern aus der
schweiz deutschland china und japan ist
ein möglicher nachweis für leben auf dem
mars geglückt der kleine mit quicktipps
sind der vor drei jahren auf die erde
breite enthält in rissen im gestein
organische kohlenstoffe genommen diese
könnten überreste von biologischen
prozessen sein und das könnte ein
hinweis auf früheres leben auf dem mars
sein der metroid war den forschern
zufolge früher ein bestandteil des mars
und hatte sich bei einem
asteroideneinschlag vom roten planeten
gelöst allerdings sei man nicht
vollständig sicher ob die flüssigkeit
noch auf dem mars in die ritzen
eingedrungen ist so die forscher ob es
also tatsächlich leben auf dem mars gibt
oder gab letztlich noch nicht
zweifelsfrei bestätigen
hiv wird schwächer die schnelle
entwicklung des hi-virus die es ihm
erlaubte eine immunität gegen das
menschliche immunsystem zu entwickeln
schwächt das virus gleichzeitig in der
möglichkeit aids zu verursachen wie
forscher aus oxford herausgefunden haben
die anpassung des virus an einen
körpereigenen schutzeffekt verändert den
erreger offenbar so dass er probleme
bekommt sich zu vermehren das bedeutet
dass die verbreitung innerhalb des
körpers erheblich gebremst wird
allerdings hat nicht jeder die
speziellen antigene die diesen
schutzeffekt hervorrufen dennoch könnte
dieser revolutionäre schritt ein
wichtiger punkt im kampf gegen aids sein
ebola ende der seuche im kongo am 21
november gab ggh also die
weltgesundheitsorganisation das ende des
ebola ausbruchs in der demokratischen
republik kongo bekannt der ende august
begonnen hatte zuvor hatte es 42 tage
lang eine neue ansteckung gegeben und
der letzte patient konnte gesund
entlassen werden der ausbruch der in
keiner verbindung zu westafrika stand
forderte insgesamt 66 tote davon waren
acht medizinische hilfskräfte im
gegensatz dazu gab es in liberia sierra
leone und guinea anscheinend weniger
tote durch das ebola virus als bisher
angenommen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who hat die
zahl der toten durch die solche um etwa
1000 nach unten korrigiert grund für die
falsche angabe sei eine meldung der
gesundheitsbehörde von liberia in der
irrtümlich zu viele fälle gemeldet
wurden aktuell hat das ebola-virus also
15 1935 menschen infiziert und 5689
menschen sind an den folgen der solche
gestorben alle informationen zum thema
ebola und den gesamten verlauf der
epidemie gibt es in dieser playlist hier
dafür klicken täglich news rund um die
themen wissenschaft raumfahrt aliens und
weltraum und ebola und so weiter gibt es
eine app und im block dafür hier klicken
alle links auch die zu den einzelnen
themen wie immer in der video
beschreibung und was meint ihr stoßen
wir jetzt auf see nahe zukunft oder wird
es noch jahrhunderte dauern diskutiert
dass wir immer mit mir in den
kommentaren und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran